la pratique arrive qu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui c'est d'être simplement
non porteur d'après préservatif c'est ça
ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui hein les
pratiques aristes maintenant il n'y a
plus de groupes à risque les autres
pratiques c'est-à-dire le baiser le
serment de main etc etc on le répétera
jamais assez ne ne ne comptez pas vous
dire quelque chose oui enfin c'est une
bêtise c'est un truc bête que j'ai envie
de faire depuis depuis le début parce
que après tout on est là pour s'unir les
séropositifs les passer au positifs les
homosexuels les homosexuels et j'ai
envie de faire un truc con mais j'ai
envie d'embrasser le monsieur qui est
derrière moi sur la bouche voilà
est-ce que il a de la chance le monsieur
[Applaudissements]
c'est un vrai et je suis sûr que dans 3
mois elle sera toujours négative